[Applause]
it's been 30 years since billboard rain
hold on song of the year was there a
time in your life that you was kind of
exactly on point you needed to hear that
message oh yeah yeah yeah no I was
really in a dark dark space when that
lyric was written I was really at a
point in my life where I felt like if I
was I was at a crossroads and I really
felt like if I didn't get my life
together and stop like do drugs and you
know had like a really bad boyfriend at
the time and I just was in a lot of pain
and I just said if I don't if I don't
change my course I'm gonna be in a lot
of trouble so I knew that I was at a
crossroads and that I either had to like
hold on for one more day or just die I
need it now in this world in this time
yeah who need you know inspiration like
this and songs that can help get you
through it you know
favorite memories from the time it hit
number one
like did you splurge or did you do
something before going somewhere that
was just like I heard it was on my
birthday on the radio the first time I
heard hold on was on my birthday
a gift what a great gift that was yeah
yeah in Tennessee in the van I remember
are the details I swear to God I don't
know I was terrible in school I have no
clue Oh God dates is stuff like that is
weird but just just just knowing that we
were so young when this happened you
know we were on the whirlwind on tour we
were just we didn't know anything except
we were a group we'd love to sing and we
just were embraced by the world and we
were grateful for that hard work
something interesting and I confess this
when we rehearsing but I had no idea
everyone make fun of me now I had no
idea who your parents were right last
night the Mamas and the Papas in the
beach what does this have to do and I
was like I just want you to know yeah
it's a couple on your own merit I was a
man it had nothing do you agree and I
think that that's kind of something cuz
like to grow up and I imagine that was
very hard I'm gauging and navigating
that with my kids I'm sure you have to
as well but being in the public eye
having parents so famous and trying to
navigate that and like what is normal
and how do I
there was no no we also have a great mom
Marilyn who's in the audience was really
she was really great at keeping it you
know steady and and being real about
things you know not everything is normal
or what is normal and you know building
our self-esteem and as people and and
showing us love and that and now we
instill that in our kids yeah it's a boy
it's a weird thing to navigate but like
I know
so since finding that out and I kind of
read anything out like one of you was
put to bed by Sir Elton John and I was
like yeah what what is your life oh yeah
well doing it your house alibi or
something I don't get it why don't I
know he reminded me when I was just on
the talk with him a couple years ago
that
don't you remember I put you to sleep
and I'm like what I know but I'm telling
everyone he literally can't mean he just
well he wanted to buy dad's piano that
he wrote that dad wrote Good Vibrations
on that was always you know solid piano
a lot a lot of memories there and he
wanted this piano he came over and he
was probably begging for it my mom said
no but he I guess I came downstairs when
they were chatting and doing that thing
time to go back to bed and put me in the
mic my bed and that was a Elton John put
me to sleep
okay the best part it turns out of this
story actually isn't that it's the fact
that your mom was like no you can't have
our piano I know what that candles mine
now so great so what are you working on
now you said you do a show a month like
everybody can find you didn't show me
but what all I know you each have kind
of different things you're into yeah so
we do our one sean month and I've got a
YouTube channel up right now which I'm
really super excited about called
California preach in yes and it's all
about okay I believe Jesus yes and so I
talked a lot about - yeah and trying to
Phillips California preaching Utah yeah
I love that passion is good spirituality
is great it is what are you up to man so
I'm I'm raising four boys whoa teenagers
oh I will be giving you a lot of wine
you just start drinking but um I'm also
trying to develop my own personal care
products yeah line of personal care so
we're you really into all the healthy
things that happen with me I never cared
about me but once I had kids I was like
what's in this do you feel responsible I
was always that way I was always like a
health nut you know wanted to know the
ingredients and stuff but yeah it's
important to me for sure it should be
important to all of us yeah yeah all
right yeah and let's see what else well
in terms of Wilson Phillips we just
really recorded hold on it's called hold
on today check it out on Spotify
and Jesus cuss for you what a pound
cakes and cheesecakes duck do for me yes
so I followed my heart and my vision I
created spirituality that's right and I
created Love Bites by Carney it's a it's
a nationwide we're launching grocery
this year it's a dessert line of gourmet
dessert there's always a thing with the
weight and the whole image but the truth
is I'm not giving up sugar I'm just
gonna have a little bit and that's the
message I think it's healthy for me
person was like look I struggle with
this I'm allowed a little bit like
Portia and Chan state you know true the
whole time because that's the only way
you'll be able to get there I believe
it's realistic yeah anyway I love cake I
want to show everybody the tape it's
awesome
okay so Kelly it's the day before the
show the night before the show I made
peanut butter cakes and then I heard
that you didn't like peanut butter so I
rushed back in the kitchen and I made
you lemon cakes so here are your lemon
cakes for tomorrow those are low bites
and I've made you I got some beautiful
frosting going some lemon marshmallow
glaze with my glaze these puppies and
bring them into you for tomorrow yeah
I've had five million of these oh right
now no but I was gonna say that if you
have a sweet tooth I think that this is
amazing because the surface yeah the
bite size so it's like you're getting it
but it's not like excessive they're like
my children my problem is I get this at
home and I don't eat just one right yeah
yeah yeah lemon and it's lemon
marshmallow
you have mala yeah yeah
lemon marshmallow oh my god we are
sisters tied to her mother I'm baking
together subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going